[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous allons livrer une guerre économique
et financière totale à la Russie
réaction de la part de l'ancien
président russe Dimitri medvedef sur
Twitter faites attention à votre
discours messieurs n'oubliez pas que les
guerres économiques dans l'histoire de
l'humanité se sont souvent transformés
en guerre réelle il est solve le pack de
Varsovie et nous on maintient le temps
non seulement maintient longtemps mais
on l'élargit à 15 pays nouveau qui sont
tous frontaliers de la Russie et on est
même en train de discuter avec la
Géorgie
assez étonnant
[Musique]
on y voit un interminable convoi russe
en file indienne des camions des blindés
par centaines se regrouper approche du
nord de Kiev mais le deal pour lui mais
aussi pour les Américains
et le pack de marché vont être remplacés
par une structure collective intégrale
des barricades sont dressées
ne deviens pas un meurtrier va-t'en
reste un humain peut-on lire ici cette
guerre c'est une forme d'expression de
Poutine pour dire que nous sommes une
puissance européenne soit payeront
asiatique d'accord mais fondamentalement
on ne lui a jamais proposé une
architecture de sécurité en Europe qui
le respecte retour à l'atelier
1500 cocktails Molotov fabriqué par jour
5 lieux de production sur toute la ville
vous jouez à un jeu extrêmement
dangereux
par visioconférence une intervention
accueillie par une standing ovation des
parlementaires regarder
nous voulons être vos égaux nous voulons
être membre de l'Union européenne et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui nous montrons à
tout le monde que nous sommes vos égaux
nous accueillons la candidature de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne et nous
travaillerons pour en faire une réalité
la réalité m'oblige à vous dire que
pendant toutes ces années les Européens
n'ont pas voulu l'Ukraine et n'ont pas
voulu du weekend pour plusieurs raisons
les uns c'était de l'aubier agricole
parce que l'Ukraine c'était un problème
pour notre agriculture nous appelons
tous les élus à remonter les
associations les familles ou leurs lieux
d'hébergement de s'adresser à leur
préfet de département pour que dès
aujourd'hui nous puissions mettre en
place cet accueil de personnes
ukrainiennes qui auraient sur le
territoire national qui est en train de
dire faites-moi rentrer comme ça en fait
par la bande j'ai la garantie de l'OTAN
ce qui va faire
Poutine et on est dans un effet domino
le président de la
notre participation au dispositif de
l'automne dans les pays baltes en
Pologne et en Roumanie Gérard Depardieu
a pris position je suis contre cette
guerre fratrie les directeurs qui
possède un passeport russe et qui s'est
souvent affiché au côté de Vladimir
Poutine il appelle à arrêter les armes
et à négocier